you
any moment now and there we go stay away
from the berserk button let's try five
all right we have a caro-kann mainline
let's avoid the night exchange ooh
you're gonna do that are ya
all right I'm weakening g4 with this are
they gonna go up on grabbing no all
right I'm not really a fan of my
position already okay I think in earlier
Bishop d6 would have caused my knight a
little bit of a headache should be okay
now hmm oh let's turn my knight in there
that's an excellent pivot square on e5 I
may want to play f3 I'm hitting this
Bishop twice why are they not moving huh
that is very weird
okay I'm gonna take that weird um yes I
get my king here a knight on f4 is gonna
be strong I want to move my knight so I
could play g3 get him out of there my
pawn here is a little bit sensitive
let's just reinforce him and we drop the
bishop back we need to maybe pick up the
pond don't want to give up the bishop
for Knight just yet let's get my queen
here pressure on this backward pawn I
have e4 controlled for a queen exchange
we're doing all right clockwise hmm okay
let's do it
they're not going to take my bishop for
a second I was thinking that was a queen
hitting that pawn twice they have a
defendant maybe I take the knight at
some point okay I could defend f2 pretty
conveniently I guess we'll go here for
starters let's kick this Knight out of
here maybe push you know I think that's
the right idea because the district is
unprotected now so I'm crashing through
on this square have all my pieces pawns
hitting it let's take here first and
take with the rook I want to keep him
active hunt down these pawns time edge
is very significant now let's track down
this pawn start pre moving oops
it's throwing a check okay that that's a
bad that's a bad pre-move oh no got to
do some time burners they started to fly
at the end back to turn okay okay okay
that was ugliness at the end and that
was a game that took forever to a lot of
two's and I'm on page two
let's try see five no matter what hang
on maybe not against d4 okay so it's
Sicilian territory open Sicilian
territory
alright I'll take with my D pawn if they
take okay they're not taking if I take
their knight their queen has to
recapture I'm on the bishop right now
okay they missed that they might resign
I have this square covered with two
minor pieces so even if they get rid of
my knight there's bishops now a monstrum
happily well I'm fine with that
I could take this pawn I'm just gonna
offer it to some development here now
I'll take and now that my king's castle
on f6 probably just take it queen g6 is
a fine defender and just a ton of
material now get d5 in maybe even play
e5 doesn't really matter if I drop this
pawn I want to get developed okay so I
get to hang on to him lock down on this
Bishop and on g4 and pawn on H five it's
a can't be broken down so let's just
double up and then crash through against
their king rook there I could break down
this rook takes pawn and that'll do it
back to term it for okay
five five a lot of fours 63 entered
plenty of time still in this one already
Knight f3 and c4
let's go with this alright let's hit
that bishop okay
made already on f7 it's parried my
knight is attacked let's get the pawn
center my bishops defending my knight
all right maybe I could have tried h4
first this is a fine centre good center
let's get castled first queenie to throw
the rook on d1 there bishop on d7 is mmm
one of those half-developed pieces maybe
bishop here would have been better yeah
should have done this because I could
get a 5 in and remove a a very good
defender of their King and maybe try for
some mate
the Knight has to play here is otherwise
Queenie 4 threatens mate in the rook so
I'm hitting h7 and g6 Bishop h6 now they
missed h7 that is mate back to
tournament 10 8 is what I have 5/5 for
less than 25 minutes left
ok 65 players and this one John Madden I
see is there alright let's try a mouse
lip Sicilian I wanted a Sicilian Cara
Khan is the mouse lip Sicilian ok what
opening do you play I play the mouse lip
Sicilian occasionally c5 Knight c6
I like that my bishop is out here to
defend against my king side so this is a
like a Kings Indian attack for white but
normally this Bishop is locked inside
the pawn chain so he'll be a fantastic
defender of some some attack against the
king so now let's uh expand on the Queen
side this is where I have a space
advantage and these pawn advances will
hopefully create some weakness that I
can't then target so we have now an open
B file soon enough with this tension
can't be unavoidable on c3 and they're
not doing anything about that let's just
take here and mm-hmm I'm just gonna take
care actually because Bishop d3 on h5
queen is hit and we have I could force a
queen exchange so I'm gonna go for that
without the Queen's on the board there's
certainly
not going to be an attack I think I
could still just move forward I don't
think I have to do g6 or anything in
fact I could probably just take twice
here I'm on the bishop in fact okay and
I'll take care well they're heading that
I have to defend him a little bit a
little bit sensitive let's just do this
if I took right away the night I'm
inviting the knight into my position
let's kick him away right now and
actually play g6 actually they don't
have any time down in time back to
tournament 1412 I was a very quick
pairing let's try something other than a
let's try Kings Indian attack it's gonna
say let's try something other than
Knight f3 on the first move so they're
getting their Bishop outside the pawn
chain and let's go for this so we have
the bishop pair it's not yet an open
position but let's see if I could put
these guys to use all right Queen
developed yeah just go here Oh
actually what I should be looking to do
is play h4 h5 Knight f6 is now very good
nice timely move to make h5 a bit more
difficult to get in so this is my idea
to peel open the H file and I don't
think it could be avoided really because
I'm there is no g5 I have that square
watched over and he's a fantastic he's
really a fantastic piece my bishop just
a really good defender of my king he's
dark square weaknesses now Bishop there
let's insert this check and then play
here
King g7 again I don't know if taking the
knight is going to net me anything let's
try not hanging my queen
watch out for that Bishop he's a
dangerous man
Queen h6 can be met with well the bishop
there yeah he's a very good defender
okay I don't have an attack now because
of this guy because of that bishop
transfer let's do this
hopefully
this pond get in the way the bishop I
think efore was there and in between her
well it's just babysit the pond for a
moment yeah it's not even going to
finish is it okay let's grab a pond
Brooke d3 he's passed now I see pond
I'll take care and let me first defend
my second rank bishop c3 might be a move
and I can interfere with the
coordination on g3 rooks III know so now
I get to get behind here can I get this
going dark square weaknesses oh let's go
here I got to go faster okay I get these
guys rolling at least okay time burners
okay I get to clean they started to kick
it into a higher gear they're back to
tournament back out ugly at the in 1916
12 20 minutes remaining in this one
c-bro I don't think I've played zebra
before he's got an extra gaeman oh I'm
paired up with them now this is this is
very important he's got a seven-point
lead I have to try and knock him out all
right let's go for dark square strategy
here I don't have my dark square Bishop
let's make certain I have pawns around
to watch out for the dark squares maybe
even get him back I can do that and
let's secure c5 I'd like to play a four
now this is a this is a very good
position for black the Queen side is
shut down and now I could look to expand
on the Kings side and I have a
tremendous space advantage Bishop g4 I
think I just get on with castling let's
secure my knight like this and he's a
passed pawn but I don't know how quickly
he can be advanced let's castle I think
I want to avoid the light square bishop
exchange hmm I don't know about that is
that probably gonna get rolling let me
just take some preventive measures
against this past pawn queen trade I
still want to improve ok Queen g4 let's
do
in g4 right now cuz he can't be defended
at the end they might try to get to my
seventh rank
I'm gonna take my clean oh I didn't mean
to I don't want to do that
ah I was a mouse slipper okay let's try
and attack their king
okay let's do this I want to take I want
to use this pawn as a defender for my
own king in case that I want to take
here on rook g1 rook here and this is
going to be blasted open let's go here
here and I get to take and then there's
made on g2 so that was that was good
needed that one needed to put a dent in
his streak there so 2320 I'm on streak
he still has a three point lead let's
stay clear let's make a decision to move
faster in that play night after night f3
as a start at least so an open Sicilian
on board Bishop e2
let's keep my knight position this isn't
really correct how I played it at all
yeah this isn't this isn't good what I'm
doing here this is terrible
this is not how you play the white side
it's Sicilian not at all not at all okay
they're thinking at least oh they're
looking to kill me Wow don't you dare do
that watch out for h2 okay
now what all right counter-attack to be
very careful this is very very scary I
don't like it um just gonna have to live
with them my bishop is he's fine
h2 is still sensitive I have two bishops
breathing down my Kings neck scary okay
g5 no okay I might want to sacrifice
here yeah I want to give some material
back I want to throw my knight in to d6
actually let's do this first exchanged
our square bishops
yeah let's do that secure my night keep
him glued right in the the black
territory I only have ten seconds what
are you doing you gotta go faster man
why are you going faster let's run to
check here hit the Queen
another check here oh let's check
um no that's not a good one okay I got
the Queen I'll go faster gotta go fast
all the time burners oh I gotta stop
playing this oh it's just too stressful
it really is oh man I think the first
time I looked at the clock my opponent
had 23 and I had 10 hmm very very poor
time management just he had me thinking
it's too fearful of getting made it on
h2 that's the one that may that's the
one that'll make me scream okay and
let's not castle so quick all right
maybe I could cause their Queen a
problem right she's on the same file as
my rook let's try and open up the C file
see a castle know that I'm in a pen d5
incoming okay I have the bishop pair
let's try and preserve the bishop pair
then challenge the piece that's in my
position Knight d2 soon oh yeah let's do
it now oh okay if I could recapture and
then there's a discovery against their
queen their night might end up trapped
if they cannot track down this pawn
what's this cleanup - that's not a good
move because I get this fork it's gonna
play Bishop here where do I go with my
queen if attacked with rook there I
don't know here for right now
Queen d2 saw for Queen exchange
have a mop apiece another Queen exchange
and I could take on that five okay so
the Queen's are off I'm up a piece
things are looking good now let's grab
this pond I have g7 hit and the bishop
okay so we have windmill tactics here
oh they resigned I was gonna play Knight
h4 into g6 and at least pick up the
exchange I think rook f6 would have been
necessary where do we stand
wait a second did I lose that game did I
I lost the game did I lose that game I'm
looking at the chat now I have a goose
egg what wait a second I have I'm not on
fire I'm not a fire I see a goose egg so
I lost that game did I oh my goodness
what happened in that game I lost that
game something happen
ah man is it a bug I could have sworn I
had time on my clock and my opponent
didn't have time I got the big al
Oh
No okay well I still have a lead but I
it's a goose egg it's a I did see a
goose egg and there is no fire to the
left of my number there okay oh well
that stinks
alright this is gonna be may know they
got a block with their bishop see I got
a zero ready it's main text here return
back to tournament no wait was that
corrected now I did see zero oh I have
no idea what to think right now
yeah it was that quickly that was like
the quickest fixed bug
ever maybe is that what we just
witnessed sworn I'm gonna sworn I seen a
zero and now that zero is just lung on
Bishop f3 throughout my night in here if
he goes back I have a night here
a lot of years all right I have at the
unopposed dangerous mighty animal-like
LightSquared Bishop tried to put him to
use watch out he might actually convert
into an animal did happen in class the
last video is f4 is collapsing dark
square bishop snow where to be seen so
just looking to double but also maintain
some material there Knight has to go to
the edge I'm fine with this and let's
move forward and look for mate very soon
why haven't I moved my knight sooner be
pretty much pre moving this Knight here
I get to play it into f3 pick up the
bishop
they should be mate yeah I have the F
squares covered with my rook back to
tournament all right no goose eggs I
didn't have fire for a moment I'm pretty
sure it said zero but that was a that
was fixed so I'm up to 36
efore maybe try for a quick scholars
catch me pre move I had that I had to go
for it I also had to drop this e4 pawn I
guess I had a sense that my opponent was
going to pre move the first few moves
sometimes that happens when they go in
for the fee and cut out setups I could
have done that in one of the tournaments
not too long back and could have won
quickly but yeah I didn't try for it I
had it I have to try for it keep your
opponent on their toes right let's
launch the Jeep on the most committal
move around all right let's go for me on
h7 get some dark square weaknesses rook
up and then over and sacrifice on g6
alright I guess they're going to block
it no I thought they're gonna play
Knight h5 how are they defending mate
now they can't Knight f6 but now where
there's mate here next and that is
unavoidable back to tournament 4028
27:25 less than ten minutes remain in
this one against Sudar shin all right
first time flying let's not take let's
keep some imbalance with the structure
and okay so they're going with a grip
over the e5 square my light square
bishop let's go here I might want to do
this maneuver I'll see ya I might have
well let's get my knight in here maybe
before it's ruled out all together and
let's reinforce him so these are the two
weakened squares and important squares
in the position a forty five a big fight
going on for them let's let's try and
expand on the queenside center is pretty
locked up it's going to take one of
these two no I thought they might do
that and then throw the other night into
e5
let's develop some and break on the a
file before they hit with a four so now
I have to do a passive move like eight
eight three so I could gain full control
over this file I think with a timely
capture they just took my bad bishop and
now I'm winning upon and let's let's
keep this so now I have some nice
harmony between my pawn structure and
remaining bishop gonna have an exchange
I want to in exchange here just kick the
Queen around a little bit I probably
shouldn't do that I have a loose piece
here let's come back let's just make
sure their queen doesn't get active
that's the only piece that's going to
get active potentially so let's go here
okay now I'm in a good spot the knight
moves I play Queen here so now we're
gonna take and I guess mass exchange is
occurring both Brooks off no
so I guess here yeah here and then into
b3 I don't want to take this pawn I want
there beep on and then get here is their
queen gonna get active I could take my
knight okay this is gonna cook this is
gonna come down to just a mouse race so
fast moves in here
yes here no don't do that as a pre move
oh I just gave them a nice check oh boy
oh that was helpful get their queen oh
no no no no anything time burners why
does it have to come down to that they
lost in time forty four twenty nine
twenty eight seven minutes and change
remaining seventy-two players in this
one okay alrighty the taco half baked
taco let's keep him around try and make
him a thorn space invader pawn alright
let's gonna I'm gonna go with this is a
setup
not subject my pawn afore is more
aggressive but this is a more solid
approach you won't be exposed and let's
do this maneuver now before there's too
much pressure on d5 where I I can't do
that
because it obstructs my queen so I have
pressure against d6 I guess Queen c7 to
defend or there
let's throw my knight iron my bishop on
this nice diagonal maybe I and at the
end dewey for all right so d5 is
reinforced I have this secured my bishop
on d3 is there defend efore just there
to recapture maybe get into the c6
square mm-hmm my rook isn't playing just
yet
let's hang on to my knight maybe push in
the center I give them this square I am
up a pawn he's uh he's a loose piece
over in the edge here Queen can't go too
far hitting the knight now
yeah okay they dropped their Knight come
back to e2 with my queen and just defend
c4 on Queen before now they resigned
back determined forty eight thirty three
thirty I think they had to take on c3
and then play Knight f6 I could have
played g6 to defend their knife but that
would have been a bit weakening for
their King side alright let's go with
Knight f6
alright let's break up there Pandu I'll
grab a tempo against their Queen and
maybe look for a quick d5 mmm let's
throw a question to the bishop first uh
okay let's break the pin could I get
deep yeah I could get d5 in now cuz at
the end if they take my night I'm on b2
let's reinforce my isolated pawn castle
rook c8 maybe throw my knight in on c4
there in a pin ooh it's very helpful got
the Queen I'm on there bishop as well
the Knight has to find a new home and
I'm hitting their knight tough to find a
good square for him he's in fact trapped
no good squares now might be resigning
I'm up I'm gonna be up a full Queen
fifty two thirty seven thirty
less than five minutes remain alright
let's try a Sicilian phobic
I gotta go faster alright let's see if I
could get d5 in with tempo this should
be good uh let's give him another kick
like right now before night g3 happens
their Bishop is very strong on a - let's
give him a kick and I want to try and
get rid of their light square bishop
actually so let's see if I could do this
really quick I'm winning upon I'm on
their Bishop castling isn't good I
missed that I was hitting those two
let's just go here Knight f5 let's just
go here on takes I improved my knight
physician Queen f6 I Knight f5 is no big
deal let's get my wreck on the open file
b2 is hit I really care about that I
guess let's hang on to him he is the
heart of the structure I guess night a
f5 can still hit let's watch over that
uh hmm okay Bishop takes Knight more
pieces exchanged let's just get rid of
him and how about I push my pawn he has
passed and maybe got a connect
past pon c4 pick up this pawn rook c1 I
push again okay just get my knight out
of the way right here watch over the
pawn and also drop my D pawn oh I just
dropped my queen are you kidding me
don't take my queen you took my queen no
oh no hope chance I drop my queen I drop
my queen no oh I gotta do time burners
and stuff never fun never fun oh this is
not good
drop my queen watch over the trickiness
yeah he's very tricky in the corner he's
a very very tricky piece when he's in
the corner yeah time burners watch out
for mates this is a very easy mate I'm
also down on top ah man Queen B 2 and
then I move my knight and drop the Queen
ah ah there's 2 minutes left to man man
ah that's so painful it really is I was
missing my Queen in that one ah man
alright
regroup man regroup finish on a good
note thankfully that won't be the last
game don't want to end like that
all right give me the bishop what is he
up to
what is that Knight up to alright let's
take him let's see how they take Bishop
takes rook takes should have a card I
was being sneaky there
so let's hang on to this guy and try and
shoo him away
alright Knight let's go here some dark
square weakness is soon let's try invade
now rook g5 Queen FA is needed
let's keep the dark square Bishop and
let's keep the Queens on the board I
should say okay that's a freebie
so Bishop here and then mate soon with
those dark square weaknesses 54 45 38
less than a minute will there even be
another game 76 players in this one yes
and I'm not going to bruiser Kai did
that in the last the last tournament
berserk King the last game even though I
knew it wasn't going to finish I try
some some berserk draw offer tactic to
try and catch the Ferrari who isn't in
this tournament I think for the first
time in a while which is maybe why I'm
able to grab a first place cuz he isn't
around wow you got first place well done
but it's only because the Ferrari wasn't
there there's the Queen all right I know
oh they resigned back to tournament
before the tournament ended barely snuck
that one in it is over the if qov
tournament final standings fifty six
forty five forty three thirty three
thirty two already I got 17 games in
Kovac with fifteen john madden with
seventeen
alright that's usually where I'm at
maybe even 17 is a bit pushing him more
like around fifteen I think to the 77 of
you that took place that took fire in
this one GG's all alright
you